Recently, I flew over a crowd of thousands of people in Brazil playing music by George Frideric Handel.
I also drove along the streets of Amsterdam, again, playing music by this same composer.
Let's take a look.
I live there on the third floor.
All this was a real magical experience for hundreds of reasons.
Now, you may ask, why have I done these things?
They're not really typical for a musician's day-to-day life.
Well, I did it because I fell in love with the music...
...and I wanted to share it with as many people as possible.
It started a couple of years ago.
I was sitting at home on the couch with the flu and browsing the Internet a little...
...when I found out that Handel had written works for the keyboard.
Well, I was surprised.
I did not know this.
So, I downloaded the sheet music and started playing...
...and what happened next was that I entered this state of pure, unprejudiced amazement.
It was an experience of being totally in awe of the music,...
...and I had not felt that in a long time.
It might be easier to relate to this when you hear it.
The first piece that I played through started like this.